I remember thinking you know if you
could you could make things go viral
that's the closest you can get to having
a human superpower but you could tip
elections you could overthrow dictators
you could start movements you could
revolutionize entire industries
I'm Emerson smarts I'm the founder and
CEO of DOS and I'm 28 years old
DOS is a digital media publisher based
in Chicago doses predictive technology
detects stories worth sharing our
editors cover the best stories which our
technology spreads to the right audience
when I was 12 I convinced my parents to
let me drop out of school and start
homeschooling myself about a month later
I created a website called mobile net
which eventually grew to become the
number one Harry Potter website and that
was my full-time job for about a decade
the remember of experiences where we had
content that went viral and it really
set in motion this fascination with
wanting to understand why things go
viral
why was it these specific pieces of
content and that became a lifelong
obsession it's just like any other
entrepreneur there have been moments in
which you know we had this
we went we're on this roller coaster of
Awesomeness we're a traffic was just
going through the roof we're up to 160
million monthly pageviews and we were
just hitting some trends at the perfect
time and then those same trends that
were going like this started going like
this and so we went from 160 million
pageviews to 60 million pageviews in a
very short period of time and that was
terrifying
and we ended up having to just kind of
rethink our business model we didn't
rethink a lot of assumptions that we're
making about about how we were filtering
content how we were creating content how
we were distributing content and it was
one of those those experiences where I
remember thinking maybe I should just
maybe we should just start over this is
this is not working and this is
exhausting and ultimately pulled
together and said nope we're gonna
figure it out we'll figure out how we
gotta fix this
and then we did and now we're we're
about about 15 times bigger than we were
when we went through that experience
which is awesome to kind of just
I can think about